Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab today. Uh,
kind of a hard topic to describe. We're calling it, um,
animal minds animal more.
Maybe the better way to say this is mines other than our own,
which would be the animals. No, that's the, yeah, we're we're animals though.
Yeah, you're right. Yeah. So we live with, yeah.
Wherever you weren't having enough trouble just talking to each other.
But imagine if I would try, if you were a Labrador, that'd be tough. See,
then we'd have a problem or a way. That's kind of what we're looking at.
How much can you really share with, you know, a Labrador or a whale. Right?
And we're not solving this problem in this show at all. No,
but we really could do this.
Maybe instead of talking to scientists about other minds,
maybe we should talk to, um, a writer. Yeah. Paul, can you hear me?
Paul, can you hear Paul? Paul, Paul, Paul, the writer. We chose to look for it.
You may now know. Wasn't named Paul. Okay. Standby. Paul. Through hearing,
he's the author of any number of travel books, novels.
Didn't he win a big prize? I'm sure. Yes. Is that Jed? Yes. Hi j d,
that's me. And like a Pulitzer, one of the,
one of the big ones and I didn't win a Pulitzer, but he,
he won a prize of my heart when he wrote that Patagonia Express. Oh,
so you're taping. Okay, great. Yes, yes. Anyhow,
Paul through travels all around the world writing about all kinds of things,
but the reason we called him is for something that actually happened in his
backyard, which luckily for him happens to be in the state of Hawaii.
I own seven acres on a slope,
a west facing slope on the north shore of Oahu. And I had very,
very long grass and someone said, oh, I know what you need it. Some geese,
they'll take care of that grass.
So I got a couple and you decided not to go to the hardware store and buy a lawn
mower. You decided to buy to animate bird. That's right. I would've deed.
So I really, really serious industrial Moa.
Instead I got to nonindustrial geese.
I actually got three two gand in a goose and this strange thing happened,
one of the Candace imprinted on me.
So what does that mean?
Show me the baby chick boy looked at you as 10 the first moving thing they see
is the mother figure. This goose became very attached,
very protective. It would sit by lap. When another goose came up,
it would peck at them. Anyway,
it was both protective and attentive.
But as the gander grew up,
strange things began to happen. First it became detached from me,
then aggressive toward me and then needed me.
It was very strange and it made me think,
I want to get some more geese and I want to read more about them and then and
then watch them. So he, well he asked friends and friends said to him, look,
if you want to know everything that's important to know about geese,
you have to read. He be white.
Most people mentioned Eby white when they talk about geese.
And of course I know and love Eby and if you're not a Marcia and you'd probably
love Eby too. I mean, what do you mean? And B people.
It's possible for people not to move,
read Stuart little or how many people read Charlotte's web?
And if you don't love the children's fiction, he's certainly one of the great,
greatest of all American essayist. Yeah, see that's the point.
He's one of the great American writers. He actually, uh,
wrote the Bible for a writing elements of style of the Bible for writing
weirdly. And it was written like 50 years ago.
So when people point to anything by a BYG, you point seriously.
And in this case, very late in life, after he'd moved up to a cabin in Maine,
he was in his seventies.
And this particular essay we're going to talk about is called very simply the
geese, the geese, Allen Cove,
July 9th, 1971.
Okay.
I've had a pair of elderly gray goose goose and the gander living on this place
for a number of years and they have been my friend.
So Paul threw open the US alien the spring,
fully expecting to learn all about these.
But then he kept running across these little phrases and adjectives that made
him cringe.
[inaudible] he talks about a Gosling that grows into, I'm quoting now, a real,
real dandy full of pompous thoughts and surely just thoughts and surly gestures.
You know, they'd come on, I mean, doesn't that make the goose a little bit more,
um, easy to relate to? Alright, take one word malice.
I could not tell whether the looking is,
I was one of novice or affectional lists. Fellas is a word you use for,
you know, Mussolini or you know, somebody else from deuce.
But what's the sin in that?
If a man who's a professional storyteller and one of the greatest ones says,
let me tell you about my keys.
And then talks about them as though they were uncles,
aunts and neighbors with moods that are distinctly human.
You could say so. Or You could say so what if you put them in, you know,
little Halloween costumes too for that matter. So what,
but I'm in the writing business. The business, it should be unsparing.
He could be quite unsparing himself in his writing.
You're giving if you write too much license,
if you're saying it really doesn't matter, it does matter to me.
And the reason it matters says Paul Theroux is it?
Eby got so attached to the idea of those geese as aging critters like himself
did he missed something deep and important about the Geek?
The elements of that behavior that is,
that is pure groups all pointed to the end of the essay. Suddenly,
I heard sounds of a rumble outside in the bond where the ganders where formerly
Greek gander gets unseated by a younger meal. Goose is a big fight,
lots of squawking and the old gander loses.
[inaudible].
I watched as he threaded his way,
slowly down the narrow path between clumps of pistols and daisies.
His head was barely visible above the grasses,
but his broken spirit was plain to any eye.
I felt very deeply his sorrow and his two feet,
the defeated Aganda goes off. Well, this isn't true at all.
When aganda loses a battle, he goes off,
gets his strength back and waits for a chance to attack again.
That kind is going to come back and fight again.
So you're saying that he got it wrong? Of course. Of course.
Here's a man who is solitary.
He's a New Yorker who goes to Maine and becomes a gentleman farmer of a kind and
begins to relate to his geese and then writes about them as though he's one of
them. I know I'm not one of them, but if you can't use words that are,
you know, very human and psychological words,
and if you can't because you're not a goose,
have whatever it is that ds have on there inside,
then what if you wanted to share something with a goose and I bet you you do.
Is there any way in which you could honestly describe yourself as a friend of
any of these gates?
Oh yeah. I would say, you know, the, the, this is a very good question. I,
I had a very surly to use an Eby white word, a very, uh, very,
um, rambunctious Ganda and he got very sick. You know,
the thing is sitting on the ground just falling its nest.
I thought he was really going to die and I nursed him back to health.
I gave him, uh, a antibiotic with a Turkey based, uh,
and it took about three or four weeks.
And the first thing he did when he was nurse back to health he is,
he got up on two legs and I came up with the Turkey base to give him one last
drink and he bit me and I thought, pop, where did he bite?
He bit my leg hard. And I thought, okay, he's back to hell.
You didn't think al You. How could you?
Well, I thought he, he's, he's healthy.
He's healthy again and he's behaving just as a goose.
Why don't you see though that if the moment of true of your true most goosey
moment is a moment when you're with the goose that you help bites you,
then you are out of this story in effect. I absolutely,
totally agree with that. In all of this, there's an implied, uh, loneliness.
I'm not his friend. I'm not a feathered creature.
I'm a human being among birds.
Well,
curiously Paul Theroux does have an approach to communing with his keys.
He takes a chair, puts it on the lawn, plops down in the chair
and disappears. You know,
my writing day ends or the early afternoon I have lunch and after lunch there's
a long sunny period in the afternoon when I'm alone,
I'm with the geese and I sit around with them and try to make out what they're
doing among each other and paying no particular attention to meet.
It's simply watching the world as it was.
You're seeing creatures who are behaving as though cities don't exist.
Presidents don't exist. Governments don't exist.
Roads don't exist as if it's before the fall.
Well as though it's the peaceable kingdom,
simply watching animals who are content doing their thing.
Then you feel a bit like Adam
[inaudible],
[inaudible], [inaudible]
Radiolab is produced by Jad Abumrad and Foreign Wheeler,
Michael Raphael, Ellen Horn,
and Lulu Miller with help from addie Nerium and Tim Howard.
Special thanks to Brianna Brenan, Kelly comedy,
apologies for portraying anything.
Wait a second. Stop. Stop the machine.
It just feels weird to end the show this way with this lonely geese thing,
so we're going to play for you. One final story. It's kind of a continuation,
uh, of Paul through in his geese,
except involves a very different guy in a very different climate. First of all,
who would, who are you, what's your name?
My name is Paul Nicklin and I'm a contributing photographer to National
Geographic magazine. Paul Nicklin is basically national geographics, Arctic guy.
It's,
I've been pegged as their polar specialist and this particular tale involves his
attempt to photograph one of the Great Arctic predators,
the leopard seal leopard seal, which by reputation is a very nasty creature.
Preface to this story is in 2003, tragically, a scientist was actually killed.
Kirstie Brown was doing underwater research and she was taken down by a leopard
seal and drown. Well, she just yanked off the ice.
She was swimming and it just came up and grabbed her and took her down to 300
feet. Nonetheless,
our story starts with Paul and his guide go down there in a boat and the Arctic
Ocean looking for seals. The first seal we encountered,
I'd never seen a leopard seal before. And we came around in,
into this bay where there was a penguin colony. And right away got on,
who's seen many, many leopard seals. He said to me, you know, bloody hell,
that's the biggest seal I've ever seen.
And she came up to the boat with a penguin in her mouth.
She went underneath the boat and she started ramming the pain,
went underneath the whole of the boat, lifting the bowel out of the water.
And that's when good on looks to me. And he says, Paul,
it's time for you to get in the water. Yeah. And his thick Swedish accent. Wow.
Were you freaking out? I had dry mouth. Um, just from the nervousness,
I was trembling and you know, I put my mask on and slipped over there,
the 29 degree Fahrenheit water. And uh, there she was instantly right there.
Mm.
Massive. Huge. Well, how huge. Probably over a thousand pounds. Oh my God.
12 feet long.
She dropped her pain when she came right over to me and she opened up her mouth
and she engulfed the front of the camera.
Her canines were up on top of my head to her below my chin and I'm basically
staring down her throat and I can't believe you managed to take a picture of
this cause I'm looking at this picture and these teeth are huge,
the canines and they're like massive. So you were doing business at this moment?
Yeah, I'm working at that point. You can even see the texture of the seals.
Tongues, like she has these little fibers on it. It's 180 degree view.
So he had to get that, that perspective.
I'm basically in the mouth to get that shot. Wow.
So then what happened is she backs off, looks at me, sniffed my flippers,
touched him with her nose, poked me in the bum, came up,
did this open mouth threat display again, then she swims away.
Wow. Just, I was just getting ready to swim back to the Zodiac. You know,
I've been in the water for quite awhile and I'm cold and all of a sudden she
shows up with a freshly caught life. Penguin, chicken,
her mouth [inaudible] and I'm sitting there staring at her and she stops about
10 feet away from me and she's got the penguin by the feet and the penguin's
flapping its flippers trying to get away.
She lines a penguin up to face perfectly in my direction and she lets it go.
The penguin swam right by me and she chases off after it and grabs it,
comes back and does it again and again and again.
Why Gam and what was she doing?
At first I couldn't figure out what was going on.
I thought maybe she was having a hard time eating it and then it dawned on me
she was trying to feed me.
Whoa.
Well, how did you make any attempt during this period to say no thank you.
No, nope. I'm so in such disbelief at this point. I'm just trying to capture it.
[inaudible]
well,
didn't you feel compelled as a social human to just offer some kind of gestural
explanation? I mean, with me, I would've made some look like con,
I don't eat that stuff. Or
maybe it's like you take, you take the penguin at that point you're like,
well I mean I couldn't rubs them, you know, penguins swimming 15 miles an hour,
you know. Oh so you me wind up when she, lets go at it.
She goes film like a bullet. Oh he's pathetic.
Cause what he's saying is I'm a pathetic creature. I can't,
I actually catch the [inaudible] exposures. Get the shot, keep shooting.
You're such a photo dude. You know. Oh I'm, I work for NASA.
I don't want to anthropomorphize too much.
But as the penguin was swimming by this huge seal,
she looked over at me and I swear she had a look of disgust interface.
So she goes off and gets another penguin and this penguin now is quite weak and
tired looking. And so I think she's worn it down and she lets the penguin go.
Penguin takes off,
she grabs it does out a couple more times and you're still not eating the
penguin. Right.
Next encounter was bringing me dead penguins and sometimes she would just drop
off a dead penguin right on top of the camera and she would just sit there with
this dejected look on her face staring at me.
And then she went to the stage of flipping dead penguins on top of my head and
trying to force feed me these penguins telling me at this point, you know,
eat these damn penguins. I'm trying to feed you. Why won't you eat my penguins,
eat the penguins.
And she would start to eat the penguins right in front of me and show me how to
eat them. She would rip them apart on the surface,
get the skin off them and she's stretching them in the water in front of me.
How much time is passing here? I mean we were talking minutes, hours.
This went on for four days for good.
And when you're in the water, you know, day after day,
what's happening for you at this point?
Are you still just a guy with a camera or, I mean,
I was starting to fall in love with the seal. It's just a [inaudible] animal.
That's just so intelligent, so a powerful, and it could kill you in an instant.
Yet you're, I mean, well, we'll usually, you are to love what you,
will you in love with the idea of this or did you really like her?
I really liked her. She was beautiful. She was big. She had this,
this beautiful face,
beautiful silver color to her and she kind of glowed underwater.
I'm just so in love with the seal at this point. I'm not sleeping at night.
I have a hard time eating. I just can't wait to see her.
I can't the first thing in the morning, you know, first sign of light,
I'm in that Zodiac
[inaudible]
and then on the fourth day is when, you know, I was thinking, okay,
maybe she's weary of me and she's getting tired of me,
so I'm just going to totally leave her alone.
That's when I started going off and presenting myself to other seals who were
swimming around the rookery and,
and I was in the water and same big female came up to me and she started to do
all these really beautiful belly like moves.
I'm photographing her and looking at her and all of a sudden she drops her
penguin, she turns upside down and she does as big guttural Cook, Cook, Cook,
Cook, Cook, cook, this big jarring noise as vibrating my whole body.
I can really feel it in my chest. It's so loud and I'm thinking,
am I being attacked?
She'd finally told me that she's sick of me and wants me off her feeding
grounds, but as soon as she did that,
another leopard seal shot out from right behind me and so this leopard seal had
stuck in behind me and she did that noise to chase that seal away,
a smaller seal. She chased the seal away. It too had a penguin.
She grabbed its penguin and brought me that seal's penguin and dropped it off in
front of me. Ah,
[inaudible]
wow. Lucky guy. Wow. I mean, what was getting emotional? We live in that.
I mean it's very powerful.
Have you ever been in love with an animal in quite this way before? Never.
Never. Have you ever had an experience with a,
with another human that rivals is perhaps when I was a kid with my mom,
someone taking care of you and feeling safe and nurtured and protected,
but I've never had that in, in my life as an adult. It sounds,
this is such an interesting species moment here. I mean,
it sounds like you're doing something you're transgressing or something.
Sounds like you're stealing something from the gods right here,
right at this moment. I mean, I don't know what words I can find to,
to explain it.
Hmm.
Thank you so much. Thank you.